hello i'm amra kujiman senior principal
researcher at microsoft research in
redmond thank you for joining us today
for the causal machine learning track of
the microsoft research summit throughout
today's sessions we discussed how the
complementary technologies of causality
and machine learning are coming together
to ensure that causal machine learning
models are grounded in our knowledge of
how the world works grounded in our
domain knowledge of the mechanisms that
govern the behavior of the systems we're
modeling
by integrating stable and reliable
patterns of causal mechanisms into our
machine learning models we can make them
more robust to exogenous changes we can
more easily interpret and explain the
behavior of our models and we can more
accurately reason about our ai driven
interventions in the world and their
consequences in safety critical and
other important domains
we're already seeing practical benefits
of causal machine learning at microsoft
and across the industry as we heard from
our two panel discussions in the second
part of today's sessions
but even with these recent advances and
the rapidly growing interest across the
field causal machine learning is an area
that's just beginning to emerge from our
vantage point we see many exciting
opportunities ahead along with some
fundamental research challenges
we heard about many of these open
challenges and opportunities in the
first part of our track in discussions
with some of the leaders and advocates
for causal machine learning from
academia and at microsoft research
given those challenges and opportunities
microsoft research aims to advance the
field of causal machine learning by
working in three broad areas first
causal machine learning models rely on
domain knowledge in our experience
capturing this domain knowledge is
difficult
how can we make it easier to elicit and
reason about a richer and broader
variety of structural knowledge and how
do we integrate such information not
only into our classical causal reasoning
and inference tasks but also into the
core machine learning methods we use
today
a second key focus is the recognition
that causal machine learning is emerging
at the intersection of many communities
including computer science economics
statistics and others we see a
significant opportunity in the
integration and unification of
principles and methods from across these
fields perhaps even leading to
fundamentally new concepts and
approaches as we combine them with
today's machine learning methods
and our third focus area as we aim for
beneficial new discoveries in the
greater world is addressing the many
practical challenges we face
this includes the computational
constraints the statistical limitations
and especially the human factors
implicated by our algorithms and
additional constraints imposed when
deploying new approaches to decision
making in real world scenarios
if you'd like to learn more about the
work we're doing or are interested in
opportunities at microsoft research i
hope you'll contact my microsoft
colleagues or myself we'd be happy to
connect with you we hope to see you at
another microsoft research event soon